it's as though I'm almost a completely
different person I feel like I've
completely shut down and I'm lost like a
show but trapped in my own mind
basically and everything around is kind
of a little bit hazy and foggy but very
dark
it's just you don't feel anything really
you feel very numb to any emotion so
it's not just like you can't be happy
but you just you can't feel anything you
can't feel love sometime or you can't
feel they cared for or you can't care
for anything that's the really sad part
of it I felt very hopeless
I was irritable all the time I was so
guilty I didn't want to do anything that
useful like to do so I just really much
kept to myself and so I just felt like I
was drowning all the time and I had this
like constant discomfort in my chest it
was just really really hard and I would
cry all the time and I I just felt
really really upset
versus my yes we just want to get out of
bed but you're lying in there and it
feels like there's a weight on you
you know when you get diagnosed with
mindfulness it's not a death sentence
you do continue to live life and while
it may be difficult at times you learn
more about yourself and how to cope